[Music]
[Music]
so my guests today are
kevin and connor from turning the tables
these guys have a very successful
reaction channel they've started
recently thank you guys for coming on
how are you doing today thank you for
having us thank you for having us i'm
doing good how are you i'm doing well
amazing sunday yeah yeah
you guys are my second long-form
interview that i'd like to do and the
format that i have chosen at this point
is ten questions so if you're cool with
that i've got a couple questions for
both of you and then we'll kind of break
out into some individual questions for
each of you does that work
let's get it done so the first question
i have i just want to know what inspired
you guys to start the channel in the
first place
that's going to be conor all the way
yeah um yeah
the channels was my
idea
um but i didn't plan on making it a
channel really it was just for fun i
wanted to show my dad a radiohead record
which i really liked um and i've seen
people do reaction videos on youtube so
i was like you know i'm gonna record it
so i can look back when i'm older and
you know just kind of share that moment
and see what the reaction was like
uh then i posted it
on reddit and uh or no i didn't even
post it on reddit yet no you know
somebody else found it and posted it on
reddit which
made it kind of get a lot of views and
people were requesting that we do
more radiohead
and then it kind of went from there just
started snowballing uh and then it we
kind of developed a format from from
there on to be honest i was quite uh i
was quite reluctant at the beginning
like it was it was summer i had a bad
back everything was like conor kept
asking me come on can you come on the
porch and we'll just listen to this
album like no no i don't want to i just
kept i now i feel bad but i just kept
putting it off and putting it off and
and then finally when we did sit down
and it was sunny it was hot and i put on
the headphones and listen and actually
took that time from not you know doing
the crazy stuff of normal life just
sitting and listening to an album
uninterrupted with him was amazing yeah
you know so it was uh so i'm really glad
that he's done what he's done it's
really changed my outlook on life to be
honest with you that's awesome and that
i'm guessing that was kid a i'm seeing
it on the wall behind you is that oh no
that was for uh the first one was a moon
shaped pool oh okay cause it was just uh
yeah i just loved that record a lot and
then the radiohead fans were like you
gotta show them okay computer kid a and
rainbows all that so then we continued
with the radiohead for a bit
nice
yeah i think i noticed yeah those first
few videos
were recorded outside right yeah we had
the setup going yeah we didn't have a
set or anything we kind of just moved
around wherever we could uh whatever
area of the house was available
we would set up
and we were using a webcam and just one
mic and uh
and kind of just went with it uh until
now we actually have designated an area
to record and whatnot yeah well we don't
get interrupted
yeah
yeah you got to have that
my second question for you guys you
started your channel i think a little
bit after yeah and you've already hit i
think 120 000 subscribers which is you
know very impressive and i'm just
curious you know what that has been like
for you in terms of having that many
fans suddenly if you want to call them
that or so many eyes on what you're
doing
how does that hit you
uh do you want to answer for sure yeah i
i you know
first off it was i when we first hit i
think when you texted me in the middle
of the night that 200 people have maybe
had watched it or was it yeah it might
have been 200 views or 200 views or
something like that i was blown away and
i'm like you know being a being a you
know a musician my whole life and not
having any type of success in terms of
like you know you know big crowds or
stuff like that i was like freaking out
in the middle of the night like 200
people
200 people watched it and then suddenly
as it started to grow incrementally and
uh one of the things that really changed
my perspective of the whole thing was
the absolute heartfelt
texts and emails and
messages and dms about about how people
resonated with what we were doing in
terms of like um a loss of a parent or
or or some some kind of strain in the
relationship and they just sort of
formed onto that and i was coming
downstairs printing them and showing
them the connor because i was i was
honestly so moved that i printed them
and i stuck them up in my office
upstairs and i because it was just
it just happened so fast but it was just
it seemed to resonate with people for
some reason and you know and and that
was really that really touched me right
so
yeah
kind of the same i mean it's it's hard
to
believe it you know and when i look at
the number uh but what really connects
with me is just the messages and and dms
and everything that we get and people
send like some really personal stuff and
and it's yeah it's it moves me really
honestly some of the
some of the stuff that we get
uh just about yeah relationships and
music and and life and everything and
it's uh
yeah it's hard to read sometimes you
know it is yeah some of the ones this
morning connor and i were sitting having
tea early this morning and i was going
through some of them and there was one
that was a full
two paragraphs and i said the connor
said it's it's surreal how
um
it's that we you know we have this
relationship and we've always been
fairly close but we're a lot closer now
with this process but
you start to realize that everybody
doesn't have this that relationship as
close as we have like and so
those those people when they're reaching
out with those feelings it's it's it is
really it's a tough it's a bit of a
struggle because
you feel for them right you really do
feel for them and and the stuff that
they're going through so it's uh on that
on that front it's it's it's it is it's
a beautiful thing i think it's amazing
right yeah i think that answers it i'm
not sure yeah no but it does yeah and i
i feel the same way you know it's like
once you have this audience like
my favorite is when i get a message from
somebody that's like
thanks for reviewing this album i've
never heard it before and now that i
have it's like one of my favorite albums
ever and i'm like the fact that i've got
to put you on something that you know
you're probably going to carry with for
the rest of your life it's like it's
amazing yeah you couldn't ask for
anything more meaningful i think out of
a youtube channel right yeah that's
exactly right
and sorry just to go back kevin you said
you're a musician i don't know
maybe i missed that in the videos that
i've watched i'd love to hear more about
your background as a musician yeah well
you know i um i touch on it a little bit
in some of the on the patreon videos and
just sort of i've been introduced i
don't think we've ever touched on it in
a youtube no video no i think it's only
been just like on the uncut you've
chatted a little bit about it oh okay
um yeah well i started
songwriting when i was a kid um i
started playing drums first i'm a
drummer first and foremost then i took
on guitar because i couldn't really
i couldn't really express myself on the
drums and sing at the same time and my
brother thought it was a bit of a joke
that i didn't have music so i traded in
my bass drum for a fake strat and then
started teaching myself guitar and then
from there i just sort of progressively
started writing and pitching to
nashville at the time a bunch of country
songs back in the 80s i guess
and then uh just playing clubs bars and
doing some movie music and then sort of
taken a big chunk away and um
just to do what i did i was in
restaurant design so
um i was working in that for many many
years and then it's really it was like
he he'll say no but it was really connor
who
said to me on a walk one day we were
walking it was you know how come you
don't do the one thing you love anymore
like and you know play music and all
that kind of stuff and i really got out
of it um
just be just the rat race just you know
paying the mortgage and going to work
and the paycheck and stuff and then i
really put music aside and the stuff
that made me fall in love with music
when i was young when i get the shivers
and the concert and you hear the first
thing and you watch the roadies set up
i had to go back and look at that after
conor brought that up and go you know
that's the stuff that made the magic you
know what makes you feel great about
music and and uh and he did bring that
back so thank you
that's awesome yeah
i have to ask if you know you said you
were a drummer and you had trouble
singing and playing at the same time
have you seen anything from anderson
park yet
you know what it's i i was i was jamming
with a few guys one night and um i was
on the kit and and it was like two
o'clock in the morning and they're like
you gotta check this out you gotta check
this out so they put it on the screen
and it was from
um what's it called
yeah yeah he showed me some tiny desk
and i was just like oh my god i gotta so
i haven't i haven't gone and listened
too much because i think conor might
have yeah we're probably gonna do it uh
do one of his records uh at some point
so yeah stay away from it for now but
you know you know that's honestly that's
the hardest part is there's there's like
the the man on the moon stuff i've
become a big cuddy fan and i go onto
spotify or i go into a video and i'm
like ah no and now i check with conor i
go is it cool no you got to stay away
from that one
yeah
i really don't know about till we sit
down at the chair beside us here i don't
know really what we're doing and and i
love it that way because if it's i have
any preconceived thoughts or somebody
sent me something right then it's it's
there so when
i'm completely green when i put on those
headphones so i don't know what's coming
so i like to keep it that way to be
honest i like that format as well like i
don't tell you until maybe the day of or
yeah yeah a few hours before we film
yeah and stay away from everything stay
away from the internet yeah
but definitely i gotta check him out
some more i think there was somebody had
said on or you had mentioned the other
day that the
the bruno mars and silk sonic yeah
coming out oh yeah yeah that'll be soon
that might be out by the time this video
comes out we'll see
[Music]
um speaking of instruments you play back
the keys back there i do yeah i play uh
i play guitar and piano uh never like
professionally or anything like that
just kind of messing around i've got
kind of an ear for music maybe that's
why i'm
you know like attracted to this field is
i just i don't know like i've i've
learned how to play instruments kind of
by ear i've had some classes but
um
yeah it's it's it's just comforting for
me you know to sit down and try to
figure things out like i'll just have a
song in my head and it's like i wonder
if i could figure out how to play that
on piano and oh where you got what i do
so yeah that's fun kevin you kind of
touched on what my next question was
going to be but
uh i was going to ask you know
do you think part of the appeal of your
channel is the fact that
a lot of people maybe don't have the
same relationship with their dad so it's
nice to see
you know a father-son team i know
there's a lot of reaction channels out
there that have you know some particular
gimmick whether it's coming from a you
know kind of background
in music or one thing or the other but
you know seeing a son i feel like for a
lot of people that's maybe like you said
maybe they don't have that relationship
but they're just looking for that kind
of warmth
exactly you know and then like the ones
that once recently with people with um
some of the viewers that have lost their
parents due to covid or
they're you know one of the loved ones
or something and and just them saying
they have us on in the background it's
like i'm going to get emotional but they
no really they they say they put it they
have it on in the background
like it's like another like the family
members there right and they're we're
just sort of just chatting and then
they'll just put they'll one fellow said
he just puts it on repeat just to have
the company of us talking and stuff and
those those hit home like you know they
really do it's
it's powerful stuff when when people are
are using that medium that way right of
course yeah right
and you said you know the process has
brought you guys closer
uh do you have any other shared hobbies
or interests that you guys would do
prior to this
um well we always shared the interest of
music uh like i would
show you something you would show me
something but it was never in this type
of format where we actually sat down
with headphones
you know no um
what other shared interests do we have
well we're hardcore hockey players well
well not players really fans i think i
think
we we play a lot of we shoot a lot of
stick right
outside mostly not on ice but yeah we're
from canada so we uh we watch a lot of
hockey together that's probably another
thing that we bond over yeah it's it's
conor's running at me you know in the
middle of something got to check the
school and he shows me on the phone
right now yeah someone does something
crazy in the nhl but uh that's another
thing that you know brings us together
that's cool
i'll get into the the individual
questions that i have for you guys
um so first for connor what's been the
most surprising reaction so far from
your dad
um
you know i think
the most surprising would have to be
[Music]
i think rodeo to be honest um because it
was highly requested a lot of people
wanted us to do rodeo
uh and i love the record but i honestly
did not think my dad would like it as
much as he did
um because he you love that record right
i do i honestly do it's so it's it's
just so differently done in terms of mix
right in my ears in the
right i'll let you finish but yeah i
liked it yeah no i definitely i think
rodeo is the one because i i had a
feeling he would like kid cudi
um same with kanye and and obviously
radiohead like i had no doubt that he
was gonna like their work uh but rodeo
was one uh that i was like well rodeo
and frank ocean uh but i wasn't
surprised with the frank ocean reaction
because you were kinda like you didn't
at first you weren't like big on it it
had to grow on you it definitely did
because it was just the lack of ins uh
drums coming in honestly it was for me
it was just being a drummer i'm waiting
for something
to come in and then it didn't and i'm
like when's it gonna drop right but yeah
but with rodeo i uh
expect i didn't expect you to like it
right off the bat yeah so then when you
did i was like well that's kind of i'm
surprised yeah
so that's my answer yeah rodeo something
about that album i remember the first
time i heard it i didn't like it my
little brother
requested that i listened to it this was
probably back in 2015 and i was like
this is not
i think the only song i liked was piss
on your grave with kanye oh yeah i just
love the the rock energy that is so cool
i don't know if it's a sample or if it's
like it's such a great rock
a rock groove it's i thought it was
taken from somewhere from the 70s if
it's not a sample it's mike dean because
he's oh okay the guy with all the guitar
stuff for anything that's right
but yeah when i when i listened to it
like a year later i think i was on a
plane
and you know with the headphones i was
just fully immersed and it was like this
is
really an incredible album i don't know
what it like there's something just
special about that
album so kevin uh my first question for
you or should i call you mr tables
okay
um
so i think you kind of touched on this a
little bit kevin i want to know do you
think that this reaction process has
changed your tastes in music and like
how you listen to music
you know what i'll tell you honest a
hundred percent 110 percent i give him
um
when i i was really stuck in the 145
progression a lot of you know g
d a
that type of writing and then you know
the standard bridge and all that kind of
stuff coming in i realize now through
this process there really is no rules
especially starting with radiohead is
that
that threw that conventional thinking
out right away for me once i started to
get into uh into the radiohead stuff and
then it followed through with everybody
else really even through um through uh
she's
butterfly uh kendrick kendrick yeah and
then there was like there wasn't that
typical song song structure that i grew
up with like i said earlier i was like
writing for country when i was younger
just to pitch i wasn't a country fan i
just wanted to pitch songs because they
did buy songs right yeah so i was always
stuck in that formulated box but this
has really just opened my mind like i'm
not afraid now to go upstairs and
experiment on in you know with logic and
just say you know what i could i could
just yodel through this whole thing
through autotune
really you know really just try anything
because it's i was just really really
stuck in this formulated thing and conor
for a few years and you know he was so
kind to me but i'd come and i'd go i
gotta check this out man i'd say this
and he'd be like yeah it's okay but it's
you know
i understand now why because the music
conor was listening to was just just
wide open and it was like just so much
different so much different than what i
was making so he was really kind to me
saying yeah it just needs a little this
and he needs a little that
but it has completely changed uh my
mindset
so do you find yourself going back to a
lot of the music that you guys react to
uh i do yeah constantly yeah for sure
it's mine's in
i'm out there gardening and i've been
listening to uh like the other day i was
walking to blonde
walking the dog to blonde and that just
opened my mind again because
one if we now we're doing the summary
the end of the month summary yeah we
just implemented that uh recently so
you yeah at the end of each month we're
gonna start uh he's gonna
share his thoughts about the albums we
did during the month and you know how
they how your opinion changed or for the
better for worse or yeah and i think
it's good because that the first listen
is is we're both you know we're doing it
for two hours we're sitting there
listening to it and it's that initial
reaction but
being out there and just walking and
then just having it on by yourself and
not and conor not there right it's just
it's more true it's because it's i'm
just sort of just doing my thing so and
then once i absorb it and take it in
then i'll sit i just sit down and i know
it's a little bit crazy but i sit down i
make notes of the songs
and then just the parts that sort of
move me and then and the structure and
that kind of stuff and then we summarize
it so it definitely is just it really
changed me quite a bit
that's awesome
my next question for connor how do you
decide what albums you want to play for
your dad uh good question uh
it's
at first
it was just
off personal preference because i was
just i wanted to show them radiohead uh
then we kind of started listening to uh
what the viewers are recommending
because people were throwing in albums
all the time
um but at this point now it's more of
just
kind of what i
feel like showing him uh like we we get
lots of requests all the time oh you got
to show your dad death grips you got to
show your dad it's always death grips
and death grips and donda they're always
like the main dms i get um but
i think i'm just going to stick with the
format i'm doing right now which is just
what i feel
i want to show him the week of you know
so if if one week i want to show him
some tyler the creator i'll do that if i
want to show him
another radiohead record then i'll show
him that i i try not to uh
you know we what we did is we
last month
we put out like a schedule we said we
were going to do these four albums
but i changed my mind i didn't want to
do the the radiohead amnesiac album uh
because there's a reissue for it this
month so i was like maybe we'll do it in
november uh so i did rodeo instead and
then i got like a bunch of dms hey where
where the hell is amnesia what happened
to that you said you were gonna do it
right um so now it's like i just keep it
low-key i don't tell anybody what we're
doing until until the week of and uh i
kind of just pick how whatever i'm
feeling at the time and whatever i think
he'll like like there's a reason why i
haven't done certain albums yet because
people ask me
uh you know
people keep asking me to do danny brown
uh atrocity exhibition and
and they've been asking me for months
but i think if i would have shown him
that
too early he might have not enjoyed it
as much as he would you know maybe in a
month from now after i show him uh some
mf doom and some more kanye and he gets
a more feel of of other records because
there's certain records that yeah you
know i don't want to just throw you
right in there like i'm not doing the
money store like
right away
just i don't even know the money store
yeah death grip so you know you don't
need to know yet it's okay at some point
you will
that actually was going to be my next
question for you too aside from money
store i guess are there any other albums
that you really want your dad to react
to but you just don't think he's ready
for yet
um
hmm let's think well money store for
sure like we said
um
i'm having a
i'm having trouble
deciding
how to introduce him to mac miller
because mac miller means a lot to me as
an artist
but i don't know where to start because
his early work uh like kids and blue
slide park i don't think they're the
greatest introduction like to mac
because when i listened to them i was a
kid and i was young and it was you know
like about smoking pot and and just
having fun
so i don't think
you would enjoy it that much
but i don't want to just throw you right
in the middle of his discography because
you won't see how he progressed and then
at the end i don't want to jump at the
end uh because you know i want to show
you
yeah his progression so i'm having
trouble trying to decide where to start
with mac miller so he's one artist that
i really want to do but i'm just
like i'm waiting i'm trying to figure
out yeah what to do yeah uh and another
album
[Music]
i guess
no no i think that's it i think death
grips is is another one that i keep
hearing that yeah all the time and you
know what scares me if i mind jumping in
here is that everybody's like oh your
dad is going to croak oh yeah i know
you're not going to die your dad's going
to die and then somebody asked me on my
instagram they said hey how do you feel
about uh just doing depth scripts i'm
like i'm actually terrified because i
don't know everybody says it's gonna be
brutal i think you'll be okay as an as
like a musician yourself i think you'll
be fine if you weren't a musician i
think that's the kind of music that
would terrify and potentially kill a
parent but
you being a drummer i think yeah i think
it'll it's going to be a wild experience
i'm sure that well you'll be okay you'll
survive
another album that just came to my head
or another artist uh jpeg mafia as well
as one i'd like to show my dad but uh
i'm waiting a little bit you know same
with clipping uh oh yeah people been
asking for the clipping
record or one of the clipping records so
those i'm kind of waiting uh but we'll
get to him eventually once i feel he's
ready
have you guys done uh jesus yet no uh
we're going to do jesus though we're
doing the kanye records now in order uh
we just dropped the late registration
video and then we'll do graduation 808s
and eventually get to jesus but yeah i'm
excited for that one a lot
yeah that one's that's definitely a
turning point i think yeah that's like a
good entry i think to the experimental
stuff and a lot of people
claim that that album was like a ripoff
of death scripts but
you know coming from someone like kanye
i think it's a really good entry point i
completely agree i'm just i don't know
[Laughter]
so back to you kevin uh prior to this
channel what kind of music would you
listen to what kind of stuff were you
into
um
prior to the channel well
coldplay
um
i'm a huge gilmore fanatic uh pink floyd
but like i love gilmore solo stuff
um
geez everything under the sun that was
sort of like you know uh old school like
eighties you know what i mean bowie
straits dire straits fan you know the
cars
that kind of stuff for us so just you
know middle of the sort of middle of the
road rock right
sure
right
well being a little older are there any
particular albums that you cling to
still is like your favorites from
you know back in the day
yeah you know what it's funny i was just
looking at um i'm such a the wall
uh for pink floyd for me i'm
i played the other day i was sitting in
the room here and i played uh
back in black and i remember the first
time i heard that from the
putting it on at a friend's house and he
just picked it up and was like
that was just for me i still get shivers
listening to the vinyl of that right so
back in black and any of the ac dc stuff
and you know and then there's gnr i went
to a cg and r a few times and the guns
and roses and stuff yeah i'm and i'm
also a guitar player so i'm from the
heavy side so i've been an aussie
fanatic my whole life right so and randy
rhodes and you know so
those just those old the old school rock
stuff i still i still get upstairs and
still crank up the the marshall and play
away once in a while
yeah are there any albums through this
process that you think you know would
go into your all-time list at this point
uh you know uh for no you know yeah okay
okay uh okay computer
uh in rainbows
and um
for me it was the the first uh one uh
college dropout
okay college dropout and then
late registration is um it's sort of
late registration overtook college
dropout for me in terms of
because i had that and then we listened
to that and then i was absolutely blown
away it just
just just everything about it from the
sampling and and and the the artistic
element of sampling is something i
always sort of
didn't find
you know i didn't find uh to be i didn't
think it was musical you know right
because i was just like oh you're just
taking a piece and you're doing this and
that now i realize
how
intricate and
how how much work is involved in in
hearing the piece stretching it adding
it here and then writing a melody over
top it's like it's a whole thing on its
own
you know and i i i just really admire
connie for doing what he does in terms
of on all of them everybody who samples
it's just something else right
but um yeah that's definitely those are
the those are the ones that okay
computer and rainbows and college
dropout and late registration or like
so they're on my
spotify that's all time yeah for now
right yeah well the journey only begins
there with yeah
let's see how that goes i got the other
question from connor so back to you
kevin uh will you ever get to pick an
album to have connor react to on the
channel you know that we get that we get
that a lot and um it's it's really
difficult because he has listened to so
much music
like really i'll play something i'll be
like how about this one i know the album
so he's he you know we went to we went
to animals or roger waters together and
he knew all of the whole animals album
when we were at the concert uh many
years ago and i'm like what how'd you
like where did i miss all this and this
was
this was the times when i was sitting in
the office and so i um
uh
no i you know i thought we were going
for the question i want an album that
you're going to show me oh yeah so what
i'm thinking is what i might have to do
with conor is i might have to do um
singles
just singles yeah and and just sort of
introduce them like singles that
singles that moved me in a certain way
in my life and i think it'd be pretty
cool to put a series of singles together
for things that happened throughout my
life then you explain then i'll explain
a story behind them because i think the
whole album would be just he's heard
pretty much everything that that you've
heard that i've heard yeah it'll
definitely be a set of singles through
like i don't know how many will do or
how that will work but yeah no i'm
excited for it because you you said you
were gonna
like kind of explain where you were when
you heard this song in your life yeah
and what was happening what's happening
in your life so it's it's gonna be cool
for me to experience and then i'll
listen to the song for the first time
yeah and then we can chat about it
afterwards so yeah and i think the list
that i've come up with so far is like
he's
he definitely hasn't heard these and if
you have i'll be really surprised right
and i'll just leave this whole
thing all right so the last question i
have and this is back to really both of
you guys um obviously your channel has
found a lot of success
in a pretty short period of time and i
think you know everybody's excited about
that you've got a lot of fans at this
point and i'm curious if you have any uh
tips you would give to someone starting
their own channel or maybe interested in
doing something like you guys
hmm
i would like to start i'd like to start
by just saying you know what conor's
vision from the beginning was really was
there was no vision it just sort of
happened organically and
and just let it and be real and just let
it happen um you know everything that
happens
happens where there's no scripted
nothing we just talk and we just love
music and i think conor said in one of
the episodes that really moved me is
like it doesn't have to be
in terms of reaction videos it doesn't
have to be a a father or something it
could just someone you love or someone
you want to share music with grab some
headphones and spend some time and then
you get a couple of things you get to
listen to some music you get two hours
away from the crazy world that some
people live in and you get to spend some
time with each other right yeah and and
connor's oh and back to going where he
spoke about the albums about not having
a sequences i really like the way he's
introduced things is because
he's just going from his heart and it's
not going okay this is about views we're
going to get the most views we're going
to blah blah it's not that it's not that
at all he
he he truly wants to me to have an
experience with the music and i think
once you do that it resonates
people you know people will see that
it's you're being true and there's true
emotion in it and don't be afraid to
show true emotion don't have to
i don't think you need to cut and edit
all the time i think that if you just
in any you know any anything in life in
relationships you just just be true and
i think that that will come through
right so you can go ahead from there but
um
yeah my advice uh especially if you're
trying to
come up as like a reaction channel you
know doing any type of music related
stuff uh this goes to for people that
you know want to react to albums with
people because i've had a couple people
message me and they said hey
this guy's kind of taking your style
he's he's reacting to music with your
dad yeah and i was waiting with me no no
he's taking your dad you're cheating on
me no i've had people message me like
hey these people are kind of taking
doing the same style same format you
have and to be honest like i love that i
want if there's a hundred channels that
are all doing dad reacts or mom reacts
to
kanye and whatever it's like that's
that's awesome i want people to
so if our format's working feel free to
copy our format and try for yourself
i highly
recommend it because
you have such a great you'll have such a
great experience doing it and people
seem to love watching it
um
so
yeah i i like i said we're we're new at
this so i don't have much advice to give
to be honest
i'm usually asking people for advice uh
shout out to john denton i ask him all
the time i uh dm him on twitter
um
but that's yeah my one piece of advice
is kind of like what my dad said is just
you know stay true to yourself
and uh
you know
that that's about it yeah yeah well
thank you guys so much for doing this i
appreciate you know your time and your
answers
thank you for having us yeah thank you
that was you know what i was freaked out
about it but it was great
i was probably a little freaked out
about it too you know
but uh
i appreciate your guys willingness to
sit down with me
have you done any other interviews or is
this personal just the first one yeah
i'm honored honored to be a part of it
yeah no it's great i'm sure people are
going to love seeing you guys so thanks
again yeah awesome cheers
[Music]